they should be rewarded for not being
people
i hate people
hi
champion champion champion
oh my gosh there you are puppy
that is a three-legged dog his name is
champion
cause he's the dog world champion okay i
have to ask this i'm sorry but how many
legs did that dog have when you found
him three that's what makes him the best
he can do more with three legs than most
dogs can do with four except for digging
he's really bad at digging and we
remember what you said about making
decisions on the house you want to be
involved we get that so
you just say the word and champion goes
back to the pound where he can be put
down and killed forever
i'm not gonna send a three-legged dog to
his death yes but i'm also not gonna
take care of him for you well it would
be nice if you helped a little
because unlike you andy and i have jobs
cruel but fair
hey ben just a few things to remind you
of home love leslie ah waffle mix jj's
diner mug new pajamas
wow there's a lot of stuff to do
box one of 12.
april here's something to help you
remember our three-legged dog champion
oh that's cute see the way that dog is
rolling around on a puddle that's
something andy does when he gets hot
you're right that is so andy oh my god
that dog is totally tom i don't know why
it doesn't look like him but it just is
it's like the dog is the essence of tom
okay important meeting in the conference
room right now we are going to all pick
our spirit dogs oh i've got to pick up
gail at the airport larry i swear to god
if you leave right now we will make your
spirit dog a miniature schnauzer is that
bad yes get in there
oh
now remember it's about finding a dog
that captures your spirit see this
is craig
oh no that is insane i will burn this
place to the ground if you pick that one
okay good choice
you guys leslie yes and ron swanson
oh my god this is larry
that's great bingo donna nailed it
you're a poodle because you're pretty
and you like makeup and stuff
came over
hey okay are you still mad at me about
the poodle thing it's just a dumb game i
can pick another dog i'm not mad about
the choice i'm mad about the reasons
pretty makeup
is that all you know about me we don't
hang out that much
it's not like you know a ton about me
you're beautiful yet cold and aloof you
pride yourself on being a loner you do
not obey you choose to cooperate and
when you stop bearing your fangs to pick
a mate it's for life and you're fiercely
loyal to your pack which makes you a
rare black siberian husky
that was so spud on it was scary
did you need me for something yes i want
to figure out your spirit dog and i'm
going to do that by learning everything
there is to know about you all right
game on
okay what's your favorite color for cars
it's gold for shoes it's red unless it's
the weekend then reverse them favorite
music 1970s funk and 1770s opera and
sugar ray postmarker after he left for
entertainment tonight favorite book
downton abbey that's not a downton abbey
okay
um describe your perfect sunday church
do the harpers magazine acrostic play my
oboe in the jacuzzi while the sun sets
over puget sound favorite movies in
order natural-born killers remains of
the day and bill and ted's bogus journey
excellent
thank you very much for your time i will
have your answer shortly
no idea
you're a cat
you're temperamental you're
unpredictable
complex and hard to read you make people
work before you let them in but if they
put the time in and prove that they care
then you open yourself up to them
right
no no no no no no no no
andy look at this little guy he's such a
little run hey there hey tom look
oh i just had five cats on me at once
you want to come in here trying to break
my record that's okay andy i think i'm
gonna keep my distance don't want none
of that animal dander interacting with
this cashmere
what's your endgame here my dear this is
only temporary until i find a way to
keep the shelter open without cutting
the park's budget hey what if i threw
together a pet adoption in one of our
parks would that be cool april that
would be the coolest thing since nsync
aerosmith and nelly performed together
at the super bowl halftime show
i think i may have found a project i'd
actually enjoy doing
helping these cats and dogs they should
be rewarded for not being people
i hate
people so leslie and i have come up with
the theme
for the campaign relaunch rally the
comeback kid
everyone loves a good comeback story
rocky robert downey jr terminator said
i'll be back and he was also making a
comeback the casual hawaiian shirt
well well look who's ahead of the curve
i was joking she'd soak that in bleach
and burn it okay so the rally is going
to be held tomorrow at the pawnee sports
building april you finalized a rental
right shut up anne i told you never to
talk to me
that was champion oh my god i'm sorry
bad dog yes everything's fine with the
rental you know i think any of the four
previous locations would work but
there's something about this place this
is a really good energy here you know
lots of natural light it's tiny and
awful and loud
and it's zoned 14b industrial waste
cleanup site we should technically be
wearing hazmat suits right now this
seems like the kind of place a ska band
would go to shoot heroin come on guys
this is a great place for a dog park i
mean look there's there's already a dog
here
why is it so dead where is everyone
don't give up yet there's a few minutes
left is this where we drop off our
unwanted cats no it's the opposite okay
i'm just gonna
put these here for a second and then uh
we ended up with more animals than we
started with this is what happens when
you try all of these animals are going
to die
god i hope you're happy stupid people in
this stupid town
hey
hey you
get back here get your cat down here
yeah oh
champion is a way better kisser than you
are babe
yes he is he's even a better kisser than
me here try something
oh
please open up we have a warrant just
kidding it's us how he got you andy and
april we have someone who wants to see
you champion come here
you are such a brave good dog with so
much spirit
you've overcome so much you are the most
wonderful dog
in the whole world
and i am so happy for you
andy got back from london two days ago
and he still has jet lag it's really
annoying we're on totally different
schedules last night he mowed the lawn
at two in the morning
andy
you got me a beer all right as soon as i
wake up he goes down hard
this has to stop
babe wake up
that's my spaghetti chewbacca babe
you hungry champion
oh my god are you kidding me
hey oren who's oren
i'm april's mom
you two look adorable just take the
picture already mom
my baby is all grown up have her home by
11. mom stop embarrassing me say goodbye
to your father
bye dad
good night sir
you